1991 Bell versus 2017 though spell from
Disney's Beauty and the Beast is often
thought of as the first modern Disney
Princess but Emma Watson in the crew of
the 2017 live-action remake of transform
fell into a 21st century heroine there
goes the Pico we change the theme of red
and blue to come my dear Bell told ahead
of your time and the 1991 original cell
was the daughter of an inventor Maurice
in the new live-action version
she's an inventor herself the costumes
from the 1991 film are absolutely iconic
the new live-action costumes preserve
the beauty of the originals with a
modern click Emma insisted on practical
alterations Belle's costume including
ditching the corset and ballet flats the
iconic blue dress includes pockets for
books and is hitched up on one side for
riding horses
Emma's portrayal fell even has feminist
leader Floria steinem's approval
spell shows that girls can be smart
strong brave and a princess what do you
think about the 2017 live-action remake
tell us how you feel in the comments
below
[Music]